OK.
It's the time of the show where we have to
talk about coronavirus, especially after this
completely insane weekend of new cases that
we've had because the United States has quietly,
slowly during early to mid and now into late
June.
We have had a period where we surpassed the
worst days from April in terms of new cases
of Corona virus.
Each day we hit a single day.
New case record of more than 47000 cases on
Friday, followed it up with another 43000
cases on Saturday.
Another 40000 cases on Sunday.
So the pandemic is worse than ever.
What we believed was the peak nationally.
In late April has been blown out of the water
by the new case numbers of late.
Now, as a reminder, the right loves to say
we have so many cases because we're doing
so much testing.
This isn't really a concern.
We're doing more tests.
So we're finding more cases.
Everything is fine.
This is not true.
And as you can see, if you're looking at the
graph that we're putting up on the screen
right now, the percentage of positive tests
is going up.
That's the blue line.
One of the things you look for to see if more
cases are merely because of more tests is
you look at whether the percentage of people
that test positive goes up, down or stays
even as you do more testing and at the national
level.
The positive test rate has gone from about
four percent in early to mid June to about
seven percent now.
OK, that's a 75 percent increase in the positive
test rate nationally.
That is insane for comparison.
Some of the states that are doing okay so
far.
Massachusetts, Connecticut, others, the positive
test rate is sometimes under one percent or
between one and two percent.
When you do much more testing, you would want
or expect that positive stat test rate to
stay even or go down if you are managing the
pandemic.
Well, if as you do more testing, the positive
test rate keeps going up.
It's very, very bad.
And that's exactly what's going on in the
United States right now.
Now we're going to talk about states that
are doing well in states that are doing less
well.
I'm in Martha's Vineyard in Massachusetts
right now.
Why am I here?
Well, the advice is the safe thing to do as
states reopen is to do instate trips that
require driving, but not flying.
And, of course, to wear a mask and all of
that stuff.
Martha's Vineyard is one of the parts of Massachusetts
that has been less hit by the virus.
And when you walk around, you can tell why
other other quite frankly, other than tourists
from other states.
Everybody's wearing a mask.
There are outdoor pedestrian areas that are
outdoor mask zones.
There are restaurants open for outdoor dining.
You've got to have your mask on up until the
moment that you set.
Everybody's doing it.
Every employee has a mask.
You can tell why the numbers are what they
are.
On the other hand, we've seen a complete UN
flattening of the curve thanks to some of
the recent worst offenders.
And those are, as of right now, Arizona, the
Carolinas, north and south Florida, Arkansas
and Alabama, Mississippi and Louisiana, Utah,
Texas, Nevada, Georgia, Iowa, California and
Tennessee.
Shockingly, the absolutely useless, toxic
Republican governor Greg Abbott admits he
would not have opened bars so quickly, knowing
what he knows now.
Now, this is like such a minor concession.
The way, you know, the real the reality of
Texas is they should have stopped all reopening
and delayed it by several weeks and actually
taken this more seriously during the closing.
Just getting any any admission from him?
Any concession is important.
He says, well, I would have reopened the bars
a little more slowly in his mind, opening
the stores and the restaurants.
You know, it was all fine.
He just would have maybe open bars a little
more slowly.
But again, this is a vile, toxic guy.
His own lieutenant general, Lieutenant Governor
Dan Patrick, is the one who said I would sacrifice
myself and many grandparents also would for
the economy and for their kids or whatever.
So you and I know that what Greg Abbott is
admitting here is B.S.
The fact that he's admitting anything, though,
is a sign of just how bad things are going
down in Texas, Houston area, icy use in at
or near 100 percent.
We don't really know because one hospital
hit one hundred percent ICU capacity, then
just stopped reporting numbers altogether.
So we don't even know the full story of how
bad things are getting in Texas.
Consider that a bunch of states decided they
had to close.
Months ago.
When they had one tenth the cases that these
states have now understand the insanity of
that, when they had 90 percent fewer cases
than they have now, they said we've got to
close now with 10 times the cases.
They're saying we have to be open.
It's a recipe for absolute and total disaster.
And indeed, we are all going to pay the price
for it.
Certainly, living in certain states puts you
at a lower risk for the virus.
But the entire country is being collectively
punished.
For example, Europe indeed will not allow
Americans to come in as they are now, just
days from starting to open up to travel from
other countries.
We are up there with Brazil and India and
Russia and a bunch of other places that have
not handled this well.
Meanwhile, you're seeing a..
Mask Patriot after a.
mask patriot appearing on social media, loudly
proclaiming they will not wear masks.
Well, that's why things are so bad, especially
in certain parts of the country.
And just as a reminder, Donald Trump continues
to say, we have the best testing and we have
the most testing.
We are twenty sixth in testing per capita
in the world right now.
Twenty sixth.
Not first.
Not fifth.
Not 10th or 15th.
We are twenty sixth right now.